[Applause]
what a gorgeous set that is my goodness
happy friday the 13th
we already know this is your lucky day
because you're watching me
what a glorious day to be alive sure
beats being dead
at least that's what i hear through my
ouija board
but being dead can only mean one thing
you'd have to vote democrat
so let's talk about a cranky jackass who
screams at people and for once
i'm not talking about this guy
i'm talking about patti lupone she's a
broadway star and a loud and nasty one
she's been around a while she was in
cats when they were still kittens
but apparently she thinks her doesn't
stink but your breath does
the broadway crank was caught on camera
screaming like an old coot at a theater
goer whose mask had slipped beneath her
nose on monday night following a
performance of her hit musical company
here's a clip of that musical
that goes on for four hours
frankly i don't see the appeal but her
diatribe was recorded by people in the
audience roll it ducey
put your mouth over your nose that's why
you're in the theater that is the rule
if you don't want to follow the rule
[Music]
wow and just like north koreans after
kim jong-un finishes a speech the
audience clapped
she continued
[Applause]
yeah there are people sitting around her
by the way
keep in mind
she's not wearing a mask while she was
yelling which is either hypocrisy or a
good thing depending on how you feel
about her face
now the audience member yelled back i
pay your salary so let's play that back
and forth killmead
salary
you pay your salary
chris harper pays my salary excuse me
who do you think you are
just put your mask over your nose why
would she bring chris harper into this
who the hell is he
anyway
allegedly she then stormed out with a
pack of white cheddar crackers which is
typically racist
so where do you stand on this do you
think she was right to humiliate a
customer because her mask slipped i mean
who the hell does she think she is a
delta flight attendant
never
forget or worship being an elitist snob
who delights in flaunting the huge power
gap between the unmasked and the mast
well when i can't make up my mind i
watch the view
whatever
comes out of their fang filled mouths
i take the opposite stance they live in
a bizarro world where up is down fire is
wet and joy behar is considered a
comedian
going to the theater yeah put the mask
over your nose you don't want to infect
the people on the stage who are not
wearing masks you know this there's a
way to do just do it right yeah don't
why are you agitating paddle poles that
woman was stupid i'd rather fight with
the taliban than paddy lapos so many
people said i want to go back to you
know what it used to be like i want to
go back to normal whatever that looks
like for you yet the simple ask of
putting on a mask is too much for some
look at our beautiful audience everyone
has a mask
please don't show us your audience
wow
ah they have a voice of an angel a
hell's angel
being dragged over an acre of broken
glass without pants
boy if there was ever a show where the
talent's faces should be covered
if they wear masks they should be filled
with oats
i don't even know what that means
a sexist would say how dare you clap at
that
how dare you clap at that misogyny shame
on you shame on all of you i think we
now learned a big lesson i sure did
but every fatuous celebrity agrees the
audience is gross and must wear masks so
the talent doesn't have to it's the
elitist grip gain power and wealth to
exempt yourself from the rules you
demand from others if they had their way
you'd be on lockdown forever you'd be
home from work forever you would wear
masks forever you know the way their
role models in the chinese government
handle it and why because they think
they're better than you they can go to
benefit galas they can have servants
trail behind the hillaries of the world
holding her train
and no not the one joe biden still plays
with under the christmas tree
and no not the one bill clinton
participates in under the christmas tree
they could go
they can go to pricey restaurants
mascalas and get waited on by the mast
and now just last night here's lupone at
the tony awards nominees event i wasn't
invited without a mask
clearly she wants everyone to die
but what a clear marker of status
you can see my mouth but i can't see
yours you servant me master the message
you're doing it to protect me from you
and your modern day leprosy now fetch me
a roll or i'll have you fired from your
peasant work
hold on a second
sir
y'all you yeah you young man and the
polo shirt in the second row
where's your mask
i told you
i told you to put on your mask
put it on
put it on
[Applause]
great
thank you now uh remember to meet me
after the show at my hotel
it's the same deal as before
don't forget the cool whip
or you don't get a tip
so anyway
lupone's outburst
is further proof we live in two worlds
but it's not a racial divide or a gender
divide it's been what it's always been
the elites versus the rest of us dirty
grimy commoners i think we now see whose
mask has really slipped theirs it's why
i don't go to musicals if i want to pay
money to have an angry lady yell at me
i'll just go to judge jeanine's house
let's welcome tonight's guests
he's so patriotic
he donates his hair to bald eagles
co-host the fox at fridge we can't beat
his chair
her smile's always pearly and she's on
air too damn early fox and friends first
co-host carly shimkus
she's like a slice of wonder bread thin
white and already baked
fox news contributor cat tim
and finally children use his shoes as
bumper cars my massive sidekick in the
nwa world television championship
[Applause]
looking good today as always i put you
up around at eight tonight well thank
you usually you're between a seven and a
nine so uh i gave you a good eight this
studio's at ten though i'll tell you it
certainly is it's jack mia
wow
beautiful
absolutely beautiful you know what else
is beautiful you
but uh their logic is they're telling
their audience you wear these so we can
perform but isn't that an artificial
divide because you don't need to wear
them
it's crazy it's actually they're
pretending it's science so they don't
wear them but you do
exactly and we already know that most of
the masks the audience is wearing are
cloth masks yes we know don't work you
see it's the it is the ultimate virtue
signal if they could replace a cloth
diaper over their face with just the
button that says i'm better than you
right that would work out well for
everybody yes uh and yet
it's trump derangement syndrome was one
thing this is covet derangement syndrome
they can't let it go and and the other
thing is if the vaccines work so well
which they worship yes then we should
all be just fine exactly but if they had
not originated from donald trump then
you could play this game too much but in
this case
if the vaccines had come
and not come from donald trump and they
didn't and we were all getting coveted
even though we were vaccinated they
would say they don't work right the
vaccines don't work and they would be
talking about adverse conditions so they
always have
a double standard which is the only
standard the left has is double
standards yes uh and in this case i i
feel bad everywhere i go where i don't
have to wear a mask and someone else
does i feel bad i say i say excuse me if
you'd like to remove your mask you
absolutely can except for that club we
go to huh
i wish i had a vaccine against
[Laughter]
carly technically the audience member is
correct they do pay her salary i mean
the people in the audience right now
they pay our salary yes and thank you
guys so much yeah just don't grow up
you guys get the round of applause for
sure we love you but yeah you know if
covet is such a life-threatening danger
to this person that she stops a broadway
show to yell at somebody in the audience
50 feet away from her who doesn't have
their mask just over their nose then
maybe she shouldn't be in public and
that's fine everybody's got their own
risk assessment but the world could be
just too much of a dangerous place for
her
or
it could not be about covid at all or
following the science it has everything
to do with just claiming the moral high
ground and the thing that i found so
interesting is the media just absolutely
ate that up because every single
headline was
patty la pone yeah not labelled no lapel
for a while i thought it was paddling i
was like oh that's interesting oh i
guess they all look alike
stops broadway show to yell at auntie
master which is a politically charged
phrase so essentially they're saying
congratulations good job for yelling at
um
smelly walmart
shopper trump follower
she did the right thing yeah
exactly you know kat i've been wondering
about this what would you have done if i
mean this is pretending that you would
actually i would never be there because
it wasn't even just a broadway show it
was a q a about a broadway musical so
that's like the biggest group of losers
in the world
one step removed from something already
yeah already horrible and and i don't
even care if i pissed these people off
because i don't want to hang out with
you anyway yeah exactly
oh sorry what was your question i don't
know well let's see well okay let's put
it in another way what if you had to
cover it for fox so you were in the
audience without against your choice and
your mass go down that crazy lady
started yelling at you
well that i wouldn't mind that would
make it fun i'd get some attention yes
i'd go on fox and friends and be like
i'm a
it'd victim great but then i have to go
on fire you're booked tomorrow
no we're not pleased i'm busy um
wow wow no it just it has wow
it's about the hour it's not about the
show you want to do a pre-tape we'll do
a pre-tape
i don't know what morning looks like
when your show is on she's just getting
ready to leave the bar
i don't know what morning looks like i
mean it's just i don't like rules in
general because behind every rule is the
implication that i can't make a decision
for myself
but the worst kind of rules are when
you're asking somebody to do something
that you clearly won't do for yourself
right
and then just to berate and scream at
somebody about that yeah she's a crazy
it's it's and she said it was an issue
of that person being disrespectful but
clearly she disrespects that person
because all the people on stage with her
she doesn't care if they breathe on her
i know they're packed next to her too
they're probably all dead right now
uh-oh never know i i don't have any
research to back that up
but i'm assuming let's just assume they
all died and she's a monster because she
is all right we're gonna take a break
we'll be right back
[Applause]
i understand what a performer feels like
when they're heckled by somebody
and i believe we watched the show last
night
[Applause]
but it was fulfilled
now your staff cares about you and they
put a pad on it
but here's the funny thing the other
side does not have a pet
so
yes how you want to handle this
all i said was that when somebody calls
somebody uh uh uh racist on tv it's like
getting hit with a chair and i did say
it was real
i did say it was real
you actually said it was not right thank
you i believe the word was phony yes
sony well i'll tell you what gut phil i
i will give you a pass thank you i will
give you a pass but next time
yeah he likes to rhyme right it'll be
your ass
but yeah she's a horrible person and
obviously she needed some attention i'm
going to keep this right here
in case you get smart i'll i mean i'll
stand in for him if you need me
yeah it's not for fun it's not for your
thing sicko
[Laughter]
anytime there's just a potential for a
little pain heads up is like i'll take
it
yeah i'm not i'm not inspiring any more
kids tonight
your 15th inoculation
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else